we will move on to the next panel on
culture art history communications and
education and we'll have two panelists
and oh it's working now and by way of
introduction my name is Cecile FOMO I
teach in the history of our department
here at Yale University and let me add
my welcome to my colleagues this morning
our first point panelist is a professor
David plank who is a research professor
at Stanford University in the School of
Education as well as the executive
director of policy analysis for
California education pace
Thank You Cecile and I'd like to add my
thanks to Yale University and to the
Ministry of Education for the invitation
to participate in what really has been a
really excellent conference I should add
that actually I'm the former executive
director of policy analysis for
California education I retired in March
but I am still co-director of the lemon
Center for Entrepreneurship and
innovation in Brazilian education and so
now my almost full-time responsibility
at Stanford is on Brazil so and and I've
been a Brazilian as for 40 years I just
took a detour into California and that
was interesting for a while but now I'm
back with Brazil so before I begin I
would just want to ask a sort of silly
question but how many of you are
familiar with Harry Potter you just okay
so it's known in Brazil and it's known
here because I'd been struck in well in
Harry Potter there's a very important
character that a dark wizard who is
known to most of the characters in the
book is He Who Shall Not Be Named and I
have a sense in this meeting and in some
recent other meetings about Brazil that
there is a character looming over us who
shall not be named and I may say that
name in the course of my presentation
which no one has done so far in this
conference and I just wanted to make
sure that there is no one who's going to
drop dead on the spot
if he is named so so before warned if
that's if that's true for you then you
should probably leave now
[Music]
Cecille didn't read our prompt question
so I will in thinking about research in
Brazilian culture and education from the
perspective of the American Academy how
important are these fields of research
in the United States what is their place
in the Academy at present and what is
the importance to the Academy of their
contribution to Brazil have you seen any
changes in these perspectives this turns
out not to be a simple question and and
I think Joe and I talked about it a
little bit before meeting and we weren't
quite sure what we were supposed to do
so my decision was to try three
different times I'm going to talk about
the road ahead for the field of
Education in Brazil and and Brazilian
studies in the u.s. I'll talk a little
bit about
the road ahead for Stanford where we do
a lot of work on Brazilian education and
then if I have time and Cecile has told
me she'll cut me off when the time runs
out but if I have time I'll talk a
little bit about the road ahead for
Brazil
and so I'll say one more thing by way of
introduction which is that education
schools are like Noah's Ark in that we
tend to have two sociologists and two
philosophers and two English teachers
and two of two of this and two of that
and so each of us comes to the field
with a very partial perspective I know
some some parts of the field very well
in other parts of the field not very
well at all so so I will my presentation
today will reflect those those
limitations on my part so so Brazil has
actually had a huge impact on the field
of education in the United States and
the reason for that is that that the the
dominant line of work in Brazilian
education faculties and among many u.s.
scholars who are interested in Brazil
has focused on critical theory and the
implications implication of the
education system in strict structures of
domination and oppression and the
guiding spirit for this work is Paulo
Freire a you know the the Brazilian
educator who has in fact been recognized
by the Brazilian Congress as the patron
of Brazilian education and this this is
this is this is for better and for worse
in in this in the field of education I
think primarily in Brazil but also in
the United States for better in the
sense that frere has inspired a number
of action researchers in in education in
both countries who have engaged in deep
work trying to change the ways in which
teachers teach and children learn
inspired by Freitas example but he is
also or the sort of fairy and tradition
has also fostered particularly I would
say in Brazil
a general posture of critique and a well
critique as a substitute for engagement
and since I never say bad things about
my colleagues I will quote Simlish warts
Minh my friend from from Brazil who says
that as Brazilian education professors
see it society is unfair
people are exploited governments do not
care about the teachers are about
education and not much can be done
before a real and deep social
transformation or revolution takes place
and so you know there's there's I think
you know particularly in Brazilian
education faculties among some of my
colleagues in the u.s. there is a sort
of infinite production of rhetoric about
how bad the education system is how it
betrays children how it betrays teachers
but no real effort to change it and
that's that's distressing to those of us
who are have been engaged in the
challenge of changing Brazilian
education for a long time okay so
Frederic influences is extremely
powerful in the US as well as in Brazil
there is a Ferrari Institute at UCLA
which partners with daddy Institute's a
non profit fairy Institute in San Paolo
there are fairy and disciples and
education faculties across the United
States and even in the lemon center of
where I work last year was the 25th
anniversary of Fidesz death and we
published a memorial volume about Fred
his contributions to education primarily
in Brazil but also in the US and around
the world as we look to the road ahead
it's safe to say that this line of
research is going to carry on for the
next few years probably with renewed
energy both in Brazil and the u.s. and
now my warning takes effect as I get
both senato everybody's still still
alive okay all right good okay
so your boss lonardo has threatened to
take a flamethrower to the Ministry of
Education and to get Freddie out of
there
and you know this makes an oppositional
stance the kind of oppositional stance
that Freddie embodied and advocated
suddenly much more urgent for many of us
that if that's the agenda then resisting
that agenda is is a powerful motive for
for many people in my field and but the
the threats and the challenges that
Brazilian and possibly North American
researchers will face under the new
government are quite real I think the
second major line of work in in Brazil
resides mainly but not entirely outside
the the faculties of Education
it often is conducted in the economics
departments and over the years much of
this work has been carried out under the
auspices of technical agencies of the
Brazilian government including a pea and
in epi often with the support or
indirect cooperation with international
agencies including the inter-american
Development Bank in the World Bank and
this this this body of work has focused
which I've been involved in so so you
may take my comments both on the
previous line of work and this line of
work with that as a caveat as focused
very very very closely on policy
evaluation and policy design and over
the past 20 years there have been huge
in from my point of view improvements
huge changes in the Brazilian school
finance system in the operation of
teacher labor markets and in the
preparation of teachers in the
development of standards and curriculum
in the design in the design and
implementation of large-scale assessment
systems and in parentheses I would say
Brazil has been a pioneer a global
private pyle
in the development of assessment systems
not only for basic education but for
universities as well and the the work
has been concerned with how how these
policies and policy changes have
affected the performance of schools and
students
hey and this line of work will also
continue it has produced good social
science not only has it produced
improvements I think in brazilian
education but it has produced good
social science that has been published
in international journals and you know
has affected policy conversations in the
US and other countries because Brazil
has done an interesting and innovative
work in the field of education you know
just taking a couple of steps back in
anticipation of some steps forward later
the car tows the Cardozo government was
a high point for economists and
technocrats friends of mine and you know
developed sort of the laid the
foundation for new and more equitable
finance policies dramatically higher
standards and salaries for teachers
introduced the the bolsa família which
has made brought brought about major
changes in brazil and began the work in
assessment and evaluation and the pay
take governments built on the foundation
that was laid down by their predecessors
in the Cardozo government with some
Farion twists so they they accelerated
the expansion and increased equality
mainly with through the instrument of
the boasts Familia which for those of
you who don't know conditions assistance
to families on their enrolling their
children in school and keeping them
keeping them in school and making sure
that they attend so and so under Lula
Brazil finally achieved the virtual
universe universalization of Basic
Education there were large increases in
secondary education secondary
enrollments and in higher education as
well the the Lula government introduced
affirmative action in Brazilian
universities which has been a subject of
great interest and curiosity not just to
Brazilian scholars but to North American
scholars as well is how is this working
since we have effectively abandoned
affirmative action
can we learn from Brazil about how this
works and what we can do in our
universities the acknowledgement of
racial and gender differences in
inequities in the curriculum and in
classroom practice and it began the
process of developing the bossiness you
know curricula Kumu and if worked well
no that was not look but but the new
standards for basic education and these
changes have generated a large and
growing body of scholarship both in
Brazil and in the US as I said there's
widespread interest in much of the PTAs
agenda including affirmative action
innovative curricula and ferrari and
pedagogy in for example the schools that
are run by the movement of sin theta
where which were permitted were allowed
and in some respects encouraged under
the petty governments and there's
simultaneous interest among economists
and policy scholars in the bolsa família
in the rapid and basically uncontrolled
expansion of private higher education in
brazil and now in the bossiness you know
could it get like a moment one of the
questions we were asked is is what has
changed over time and and i think our
colleagues in law talked about this
yesterday and i'd certainly true in
other disciplines as well that when i
began working in brazil 40 years ago
there was some deference i think some
sort of unearned credibility for north
american scholars in brazil and that has
gone away probably as they've gotten to
know us better but also as the brazilian
academic community in education as in
other disciplines has been greatly
strengthened so we now see a lot of
close cooperation between brazilian
scholars and their North American
counterparts both in the SIRT in the
fray and tradition as they sort of
exchange ideas about how to how to
resist the state but also among
economists and
others working on public policy okay so
that's my first answer to the to the
prompt that was that was posed the
second answer I'm going to talk a little
bit about the the Lemon Center at
Stanford University and the work that
we're doing on Brazilian education the
center was founded eight years ago and
again things happen sometimes sort of by
accident for faculty members in a small
faculty the Faculty of education at
Stanford is about forty five people and
it turned out that four of us spoke
Portuguese and had extensive experience
in Brazil so I had begun my career as a
Brazilian esteem karna I has worked on
in countries around the world but has
spent considerable time in Brazil and
speaks Portuguese [ __ ] Stein is a
scholar of science education and
education technology and is himself
Brazilian and Eric Bettinger was a
Mormon missionary in San Paolo and so
learning to speak Portuguese had never
worked on Brazil but was fully equipped
to work on Brazil and has since become
quite engaged in scholarship on
Brazilian education and we've been
joined over the years by visiting
professors including head beckett Arlo
and Catherine Muller both of whom who
have done excellent work on education in
Brazil so the the mission of the lemon
Center is to support improvement in the
performance of the Brazilian education
system by conducting research and
engaging in project work that seeks new
strategies for educating young
Brazilians and so we've worked closely
with Brazilian colleagues on a variety
of projects aimed at supporting
innovation and improvement we have
brought more than 150 students and
visiting fellows to Stanford for
extended periods of time over the past
eight years to advance their own
research but also to partner with us on
projects within the center we have
strong programs of research in the
economics of education in pedagogy
and educational technology along with
individual projects and other
disciplines we have well we we put
together we organized a meeting for
brazillian it's a subset of resilience
okay I was afraid of this okay yes I
told you you'd have to give me a warning
because once I get going I it's hard to
stop okay
so in any case are the bibliography of
publications from the centers about six
pages long now and growing so we are
engaged in multiple projects a project
called PG the program of the especially
czar sound of San Shi which is which has
established partnerships with eight
universities three public and five
private and also with municipio Salvador
Bahia to change the ways in which
teachers are trained in Brazil which is
a major failure of the Brazilian public
universities and really one of the great
obstacles to bringing about improvement
in Brazilian education we've just
established a new Center in Brasilia
called Despero and a batch democrática
sound dated as a the chelate leaders of
that project are testing the social Cruz
who works for the full national funders
longitudal Vargas in Brasilia and
Mauricio
holanda who was the Secretary of
Education in serra were working in
through death threats they were working
with other policy organizations
including SE p at the funda social to do
Vargas in Rio and we're hoping to work
with our colleague Daniel Vargas in the
center that she's establishing on
federalism and education in Brazil I and
others have been working on the
challenges of implementing the Bosnia
now and now the heifer Madhu encino made
you which have both been approved by the
Consejo Nacional de JICA so but you know
remain very much on paper the the
process of bringing them to Brazilian
schools and classrooms is just beginning
we have a project in Sabra and Sarah to
develop new science new both new
materials and new techniques for science
education and my colleague Eric
Bettinger has been working on a project
on what economists called nudges
small changes in the environments of
students and parents that lead what we
hope lead to big changes either in their
behavior or in their mindsets the center
the Lemon Center has established
partnerships with multiple states and
federal agencies to share data and
conduct analyses of how different
policies and institutional arrangements
affect student learning so at the center
we house data from the states of some
pablo Pernambuco and sierra we have data
sharing agreements with meki in epi and
sometimes he pea it pays a little little
more complicated so how many minutes
have elapsed now okay - left okay so I
will I will simply say that that many of
my colleagues over the past two days
have talked about this as a liminal
moment in brazil or a fork in the road
or a turning point and i think as i
don't see him here but as Professor
Carlos Yvonne Simonson suggested
yesterday I think we're about to see a
resurgence of some old debates Brazilian
debates about education in a
contemporary context and you know that
these fundamentally have to do with
whether the new government will continue
or reverse changes that have been made
by Brazil's recent governments including
the professionalization of teaching
affirmative action and university
admissions and curriculum reform the the
the third one of these is of particular
interest to me because the question of
who owns the curriculum has a long
history in Brazil in the 1950s and 60s
there was a 15-year standoff in the
Congress over questions that were
basically that focused on the Catholic
doctrine of subsidiarity that asserted
that education was the responsibility of
parents in the church and the state
should not be involved and the principle
of libertagia to Encino which which
persists which basically argued that
that education was a private affair and
the state should only intervene if
private agencies failed to provide
education for children in our
contemporary context that the place of
the Catholic
these debates has been taken by the
evangelicals but the arguments remain
very much the same you know that who
decides about the curriculum should it
be parents and pastors and there's a new
new actor in these debates which is
organized teachers who colleague of mine
came back from Brazil adjustment
conducts some interviews and he told me
that a teacher that he interviewed said
well all curriculum is fascist you know
that that you know teachers should have
complete autonomy in the classroom this
is a sort of Frary and notion that the
classroom is a is a discourse space in
which teachers interact with students
and that curriculum is fascist so so and
then we have the bossiness you know come
on which is the state asserting its
right to tell you know all teachers and
all students what it is exactly the
teacher students should learn at
different grade levels so the question
of how this moves forward under under
the new government I think is an open
question and I think a portentous
question for Brazil you know whether the
government will allow implementation to
continue or whether they will discover
that the new standards are fatally
infected by Karl Marx and Paulo Freire
day or whether they'll decide that they
were written in dialect or sick parental
and the the the further set of questions
it has to do with what the
implementation of bolson our own
priorities will look like in practice on
the campaign trail II had two explicit
priorities what he called educational
sent box tillu which meant basically the
teachers should not ever talk about
politics in their classrooms but only
talk about useful information whatever
that means and this is manifested you
know since the election in attacks on
universities and individual teachers and
on the national readiness examining for
including an item focused on the dialect
of secreto
and the second priority that both senato
articulated was banning discussion of
sexuality and gender in brazilian
schools on the argument that such topics
should be the exclusive domain of
parents and you know he has not taken
office yet so it's unclear how this will
play out as I said two
in colleague this morning our experience
in the United States suggests that when
people say things on the campaign trail
they mean them and that things are
likely to be if anything worse rather
than better after he takes office but
there are a lot of pending against
issues in education and a lot of anxiety
thank you
[Applause]
thank you very much our next panelist is
Professor Yosef the Amman Jay Carter
Centennial professor of communication
from the University of Texas at Austin
all right I figured at this point of the
day everybody would probably benefit
from having slides so bear with me and
we've talked about that so what I wanted
to do my interpretation of the of the
charge to us was to think about where
Brazil has been an important case or
example in both the US and international
debates about media and communication
study and interestingly enough it has in
fact on the first point I mean I didn't
emerge from college as it would be
Brazilian distinct maybe it sounds like
some people do but what happened to me
it was I got to graduate school and got
it I was doing international relations
with an emphasis on media and in fact
became a diplomat for eight years which
is what my grad school the Fletcher
School of Law and Diplomacy really
wanted me to do I also seemed like a
great way to get to Brazil and do a PhD
on Brazil but I did that in part because
in my coursework I'd gotten very
interested in who were going to be the
big emerging media powers in the world
that we're going to challenge what then
seemed like American dominance the
prevailing theories and the early 70s
when I was studying all this was very
much about cultural imperialism
and so I'm gonna concentrate a bit on
that because I think in many ways and my
discipline at least Brazil's biggest
impact in the world has probably been
being used by me and several others as a
very direct challenge to that you know
emerging finally in Brazil being seen as
a brick an emerging power which we
haven't really talked about maybe that's
seen as a dead issue by people but in
and I have a very lively debate going
with several international political
economy colleagues who say well China
Dwarfs everybody else and I usually say
back brazil is actually more important
communication power than china and i
think it is and so i want to talk about
that as much as anything I think today
but here's kind of a menu of what I and
I'm not going to talk equally about all
of this but I think it's interesting
Brazil is a very valuable object of
study also and how a variety of elements
government private industry etc have
helped construct a national identity and
which TV particularly became very
powerful in the construction of national
identities when people look at that
globally in the US and in other
countries Brazil also emerges is a
pretty interesting fairly powerful case
I do one definitely want to talk about
that a bit it's definitely an example of
hybridity I think that's probably been
talked about I love to start my classes
by saying that the Brazilians invented
high bit Britta Dee thereö with
anthropology equal to Al and love to
kind of show them you know examples of
that as a way of getting them to think
seriously about the idea and so it's
been a very crucial case in a variety of
things I think starting in some ways
with development arguments certainly
with the arguments about cultural
imperialism and even now I think both in
globalization writ large and in various
specific things like the election of
Heath we shall not be named which had
was greatly impacted by whatsapp which
simply a year or two ago I began to
research because I was very excited
personally by a cult ecologic extension
that gave poor Brazilians with only a
feature phone not even a smartphone a
way to communicate with each other and
it's still very exciting but as we've
discovered in our election with social
media
it's very powerful for good and bad you
know and particularly whatsapp compared
to Facebook is essentially invisible
it's encrypted to a level that people
have no idea what's being passed around
as we discovered in the very last minute
discovery of a number of powerful
economic groups contributing to the
election of huge and L shall not be
named by sending things around the
around Brazil on what's that
and I say though I think Brazil is very
I mean when the New York Times
Washington Post etc Guardian have
headlines about how what's happened to
elect your a president in some ways even
a way even more visibly powerful than
what happened with Trump and Facebook
then we've got an interesting thing to
study and in some ways it's always a
discussion of when people get discussing
the state and media Brazil is always an
example and I think Brazil's also as
this with this with this what's up case
very much an exam and an innovator and
new media so in many ways we do have
this very strong discussion which is
still very much in play about how Brazil
compared to other countries used first
things like sport Samba but try do nacio
now for a very specifically to help
construct a national identity and then
how a see Chateau but dealing with to be
kind of in some ways double down on that
but also frankly failed cases of failure
just as interesting as cases of success
and nobody remembers that type a to P
probably should have been the Televisa
of Brazil but was so disastrously badly
managed that it fell apart and so
Brazil's an interesting case both for
success and failure in some ways one of
the big issues when we look at the
interaction of US and Brazil in this
field of media and communication study
is that many people particularly
political economists tend to see the US
as essentially imposing its format and
it's its patterns on Brazil and in fact
for much of the time I got there in at
first to 1976 and a couple of years
later one of my friends a woman
Mariya padule at wish be said estamos so
Ferrando MLG cell adorned IANA Adorno's
curse that people were so preoccupied
even blinded by political economy and
the perception of enormous unchangeable
power in the hands of global the a they
didn't understand how it had been put
together in detail and B didn't really
realize that there were a lot of
transformative things going on it going
on with it that you had to step outside
of political economy to understand but
still I'm in constant debates like just
last year somebody said alright you're
in the expert on telenovela
so if tell them if we're still just
having soap opera selling soap what does
it matter that it's made in Brazil and
so I had myself up off the floor and say
really you have you you don't think that
cultural content matters it's only
whether it sells soap or not so that's
my basic when we reduce my discussions
with political economy sometimes it
comes down to that Rieti you don't
understand that the content matters and
so it's it's interesting that's still a
very large preoccupation and in fact
invisible things have happened like this
is an example by a friend of mine at
wish B and now instituto mental beast
who's looked at the how brazil exhausted
the idea of the anchorman and there's
plenty of examples perhaps the biggest
one let's skip here for a second is the
famous telenovela brazilians get very
angry if you say well you know there is
a genealogy that goes from
colgate-palmolive through cuba where the
telenovela was created down to brazil
and people you know there was a very
robust argumentation about that but i
think in some ways it's an interesting
example where you can see overt american
influence literally colgate-palmolive
prompted the creation of the devil
novella
people from cuba fled castro and came to
brazil to help propagate the telenovela
i mean one of the great unintended
consequences of history is that fidel
probably didn't realize it well while
eliminating commercial culture in cuba
he doubled down on it and
of Latin America by exiling all these
really talented professionals to all
these other countries that then was a
process where say the the main right
novela writer for global for a couple of
years basically never wrote about Brazil
cuz she didn't think Brazil is not a
romantic country so I can't write about
it so she was exiled by about 1970
finally and they begin to realize that
writing about Brazil itself and creating
a new form of television entertainment
for Brazil based on the telenovela based
on the Cuban telenovela well it's
actually a pretty interesting idea
and something that's preoccupied me so I
I tend to work both contemporarily
whatsapp and both senado as well as
historically and I'm still riveted by
why it was that the the Brazilian
dictatorship in 1970 let a guy whose
other main alternative that year was to
become a MIDI a member of the Committee
of the Central Committee of the Cuban of
the Brazilian Communist Party dias gomez
they let him become head of telenovela
production for TV Globo and the TV Globo
who was supposedly in bed with the
military government wanted him and so
we'll come back to that little mystery
in a moment but it is you do see moments
of heavy us impact so here's a see
shadow buddy on initiating day of a 2p
with RCA and invisible influence and
apparently supposedly had big a big
extravaganza for the first day but
hadn't thought about what comes next so
apparently both he and his technicians
said to RC the RCA technicians to the
next day well what do we do now and so
there was quite a bit of influence but I
think the interesting story in the
longer run is how that influence gets
transformed so and 2p in many ways is a
really interesting organization a lot of
my information like I've done a lot of
reading but I've also done about 25
hours of in-depth personal history with
a guy named Joel Wallach who was the
time-life delegate who helped start TV
Globo
and stayed on as their financial manager
for another 15 years in the initial
violation of the Brazilian Constitution
although he became a citizen so he could
stay on and it's interesting how
something can seem powerful but as
Wallach said in the interview but it was
TV TV TV TP should have been able to not
Globo out but it was the worst run TV in
the world so there's an interesting
point there which is in some ways the
story part of the story of the 20th
century with media and Brazil is going
between extreme decentralization which
tv2 P had all 24 of their condo Minos
their local regional owners had equal
power so they would never ran the same
program at the same time which makes
modern advertising among other things
impossible and so they it was
interesting very innovative in many ways
but the thing that one reason I wanted
to go to Brazil is I was expecting a
complete perfect example of cultural
imperialism because time-life had helped
start TV Globo and had been there up
until at least 1970 if not later
and so here's Joe Wallach getting the I
forget the name of the order it's the
met the the main order then a non
Brazilian can get the ordinal heal but
Uncle Cruzeiro do Sul so they
essentially have a knighthood in Brazil
and for his contributions to Brazilian
culture although most of my colleagues
in media studies saw him as the devil
incarnate for having helped
commercialize Brazilian TV so it's in it
and it's so this was kind of essentially
what I went to study and it's still a
hugely controversial a lot of people
look at this instance and assume that
Brazilian TV is now condemned to some
sort of Perpetual servitude before the
US model and also to a kind of damnation
for being commercial and this is an
interesting point there's still a
lingering thought that all commercial
media are by by their very nature
globalized capitalist and not to be
trusted and so that's I found this very
very strong in Brazil when I first got
there and I've had this long dialogue
with lots of Brazilian colleagues about
this because in some ways they're not
they're not wrong I mean time-life
probably did help consolidate commercial
TV in Brazil probably did help nail down
consumer capitalism in Brazil so it had
a hugely powerful effect and it had
precisely the effect that the government
wanted if you look the military planning
documents from the superiority scholar
Sapodilla rajagaha they had a very
specific role for TV in mind and it was
exactly this role and so if it hadn't it
turned out not to be Tab A to B but and
turned out to be TV Globo a vision of
turning Brazil into a consumer
capitalist society so that presence
would never even want to have an leftist
revolution afterwards that was the the
goal to make people happy with consumer
society and so it's an interesting
question if that that probably does
almost a priori constitute cultural
imperialism but what it doesn't do is
tell you about all the interesting
cultural development that then took
place and so I think you can make a
really interesting argument that that
particularly TV it's one reason why
Brazilian TV gets studied in the world
it's a very powerful case in a number of
the big big issues including now how TV
global will cope with Netflix which is
something I'm currently studying so in
some ways if you think about the the TV
time live TV global example time life in
theoretical terms had to had all those
things things that thought it knew and
wanted to localize Mourinho had some
things he wanted he wanted to
essentially globalize what time life had
to offer and I frankly I would say it
was 99% the latter with the way it
played out fact I actually interviewed
the international head of time life at
the time for my dissertation is as you
know we were completely ripped off by
the Brazilians they borrowed all our
technology stole one of our best guys
got a got a interest-free loan for six
years and kicked us out exactly when we
were becoming profitable Brazilian
govern in 1970 that yes this really does
violate the Constitution and we really
should kick these guys out right about
now and so it's it's a really
interesting case of who's
got what power you would think that
something like time life would be
enormous ly powerful in the world but
not in Brazil and when I teach globally
I would use the comparison of what
happened the Rupert Murdoch when he went
to China which wasn't pretty from
Murdoch's point of view very powerful
actor in the world China completely
controlled him and so you know it's an
interesting way to teach about
globalization in some ways using strong
cases like this so one of the guys I'm
currently working on is this guy Dias
Gomes who had the choice between being
hit in the communist party's Central
Committee but there were two communist
parties and he was in the one that was
more about gradual education over time
and less about the one less
revolutionary in the sense so what he
wanted to do was tap little poeple our
popular theatre and was very good at it
had done some very famous plays and one
of my favorite films from the cinema
novo pocket orgy promises which is a
fantastic film and the military
ostensibly seemed to be terrified of
this guy because they let him they
wouldn't let any of his plays be
performed but TV Globo gave him an
interesting chance to essentially write
novellas and I loved I loved this
reaction that they will chiapoe palaka
to sannyas you know this is the thing I
always dreamed of having a popular
theater for millions of people on TV and
so I think this is the other side so in
some ways TV help bring Brazil into the
modern capitalist system but it also
offered a bunch of leftist playwrights
their chance to talk about their vision
of Brazil in the context of
modernization under the military
interestingly enough and I think you
know trying to summarize all that well
Berta muddy and you've got everything he
could possibly want it because these
guys made him a lot of money the
military decided that they were going to
suffer a few slings and arrows but that
they were going to get a capitalist
modernity that they very much wanted and
that on the other hand these guys
despite having to accept nailing down
consumer society they kind of felt that
we had to have the bourgeois revolution
first anyway so let's cooperate let's
make it work
and then let's push education via
popular theater all right so two last
things to think about one is that
Brazil's been very innovative in using
technology particularly for alternative
media well my personal favorites is
video on the villages which is still
going favela media like Viva favela in
Rio and just even the continued use of
folk media like Cordell it's that shot
is from a year ago I went to one of the
big four hall centres and doing a side
project on fo ho and it's interesting
how central the the imagery of Cornell
still is and that 4ho itself is the
basis for regional identity in some ways
Brazil is also very very intimate
innovative example they are perhaps the
biggest adherents enthusiasts of social
media in the entire world perhaps you
could argue I don't want to be
essentialist but prisons are very social
and this is maybe not a surprise that
they took to things like our Facebook
and now whatsapp very easily quickly and
avidly so the whatsapp cases it's
problematic and interesting because it
was really only on the last few weeks of
the campaign that the investigation by
quality Sao Paulo and some others
discovered that an enormous amount of
fake news was being circulated really
off the radar via whatsapp and that it
probably you hate two things say things
like decisive but this is one of those
cases where I don't like to be a
technological determinist or use strong
language like this but this seems very
very very powerful because both senado
didn't have much access to conventional
media he didn't have many minutes and
that in the in the audio got to ito he
didn't have much access to TV but he had
he and the businessman backing him
played this very very very well alright
one last thought which is about
interaction and so one of the things I
think as I've been lucky with I
discovered Brazilian communications I
could day me at about the same time that
they were founding a National
Association called inter comb based in
Sao Paulo and I got sort of got baked
into the genesis of it so I've been
there that gringo for a long long time
to the point where they actually have
now created a collaboost Brazilian
Easter's and I was the preeminent that
was the the print the first first
inductee but it's interesting because
I've had this dialogue with him for over
40 years about the role of the outside
observer and it's instinct I think at
least in media study they've come to
decide that the role of the outside
observer is actually pretty positive as
long as we're kindly disposed toward
them in not going there to sort of use
some horrible acts to make Brazil look
bad you know as long as we show that our
kind of good faith they're very
interested you know what the outsiders
think and it's to the point where it's
literally been institutionalized with a
Academy of brazilian Brazilian s and now
has like 30 people in it and so and we
have a every two years colloquium
comparing communication study between
the two countries linked to their big
national association so maybe it's just
been in my field but we've been very
fortunate I think in some ways to have a
very active relationship and a lot of
dialogue back and forth and seemingly a
kind of nan-oh but nobody's been
particularly worried about playing power
politics we know more than you do no you
can't study this because it's ours
that so far hasn't happened too much and
for that I'm very thankful so Adrian
thank you and I appreciate your
intention thank you very much for - for
provoking presentations um listen I'm an
academic in front of a microphone so I
will before open before opening the
floor to question I feel compelled or to
share a few thoughts maybe to round up
the panel on the topic of art history
that was also I mentioned in the title
so I will do this very quickly because
lunch is calling us but I want to
mention four points the first one is to
echo much of what was said in the
preceding panel on history about the
issues of translation of works for
teaching
and research language training study
abroad and gateway courses that are
crucial to forming the next generation
of brazilian a-- stin the US but in
terms of language training I just want
to you know I have an optimist extent in
that we're in a country that has a huge
minority of native or heritage Spanish
speakers which basically means they are
one semester of Spanish Portuguese for
Spanish speakers away from being
proficient in Portuguese so there is
tremendous potential there the second
point is to talk specifically to art
history as a field in the u.s. Brazilian
art history and then artistry in general
in Brazil which are both relatively
small fields in particular in comparison
to adjacent disciplines such as
anthropology or history and so there is
much a solidarity I think between art
historians in Brazil and Brazil in East
art historians in the u.s. in our desire
to grow the field together for many
reasons and there has been a rent of
initiative by the Getty foundation for
example to grow together the third point
is also specific to art history that has
to do with the excellent mention of
digitization and the making ways of
having archives and patrimony accessible
but in for art history and material
culture and a material culture
digitization is simply not enough
we can't download the works of art and
that's when cultural corporation as
educational corporation would be key in
terms of support for museum programming
traveling exhibitions and in the US for
example I think the last huge Brazilian
blockbuster exhibition of art was
probably the Brazil body and so in 2001
so kind of a Redux version of the most
notorious Cobra Mentos
that was at the Guggenheim and Museum
and the art scene in Brazil is really
one of the most exciting in the world
and that is one of the ways in which we
can think of collaboration and the
fourth point has to do with diversity
and inclusion in the field of Brazilian
studies and as we all know there are
many Brazil's and I think one way to
grow the field is really to foster the
study of the many faces of Brazil so to
be optimistic again you know I really
see that working together at fostering
the creation and the growth of a new
archive new collection new approaches is
really a way forward to get more
students and more future Brazilian is
excited about the field in the US and
innovation and creativity are the
gateways there to reach sure but also a
bigger a bigger field so thank you for
for your patience and I would like to
open the floor to questions to our
panelists my question is for Joseph so
in thinking of communications the road
ahead what do you see the role of
academics if any in trying to mitigate
all this wave of fake news that brings a
lot of harm not just in the siting
elections but for example in public
health as well which is the field that I
work is there anything that can be done
it really is a good question and for I
wish I could be a little bit more
optimistic because for better or worse I
mean whatsapp had mostly been notable in
Brazil over the last four or five years
because judges kept trying to seize
records of conversations between drug
traffickers and it was never possible
I mean whatsapp would simply be shut
down before they would turn over
any records of any transaction or core
communication so part of it depends a
little bit on what Facebook the owner of
whatsapp decides to do do they want to
cooperate with research and
investigation I mean Facebook is finally
in the u.s. opening up to research about
Facebook and partes frankly as part of a
PR effort to show that they're doing
something like one of my colleagues is
looking at the Russian Facebook case
with evidence provided by Facebook and
so there's some potential for Facebook
deciding that it has to do something and
opening it up but on I think this is one
where the technology is so far in front
of the ability to study or regulate that
it's I'm not terribly optimistic I mean
to some degree probably the bigger
longer-term answer would the people have
to there needs to be kind of a media
literacy campaign aimed at people who
were brand new to all of this because
frankly one of the problems in Brazil is
that you had suddenly tens of millions
of people with this new capacity on a
very simple phone to forward things get
things etc and they were not really
prepared for it in any way they hadn't
had experience with the Internet they
hadn't had the experience of sort of
growing up historically with the
internet and learning that not
everything on the internet is true and
that and so tens of millions of people
suddenly were getting these things that
because their uncle sent it to them they
just kind of assumed it would be true
and their uncle probably didn't know
that it came from a businessman who was
working on behalf of bull senado if you
trace it back you know 20 iterations and
so it'll be interesting because as we
just covered with Trump here there's no
real interest in investigating
somebody's technological innovation that
got you elected you know Trump has very
little interest in helping with
understanding the Russia question I
don't think that bol senado is gonna be
very wildly excited about helping
understand how whatsapp helped him get
elected that would be dumbstruck
if there were to be much in if there
were to be much intervention or even
study say by the new Brazilian
government but I think so I think this
question I think there needs to be a
focus on media literacy for all these
new users of this technology that don't
know for instance to be skeptical I'm
not trying to be condescending I mean
it's a thing to process people go
through and there's a new technology
that you're just beginning to use and
something a fairly powerful intervention
and manipulation gets done with that
technology I'm not blaming the people
who were impressed by this stuff or or
even maybe decided to move their vote
because of this stuff but one of the
longer-term solutions will be that and
again with a government that's not
likely to be interested it will have to
come from civil society and other actors
I think
I have a question really for for both
presenters which is about our
understanding of what literacy does for
me it would what you just said would not
explain why the highest support for bowl
Sanada was among about college-educated
68 percent and in the past 15 years
there was an enormous increase in simple
literacy you know less enough about
dismal and an enormous increase also in
functional literacy as defined by the
statistical agency that keeps surveying
it from maybe 10% of the population
functionally literate able to deal with
two paragraphs and compare two
paragraphs to more than 30% of the
population functionally literate so what
has been I mean I I really this is a
real question for me what is the impact
on a society on a culture of such an
enormous leap in functional literacy
[Laughter]
when I was in graduate school you know
but a much bigger share of the world's
population was illiterate than literate
and that's changed over over my time my
time in the profession so what we talked
about back you know now 40 years ago was
well literacy may the capacity to write
things down and to recover them you know
changes the way people think about the
world it sort of establishes a base of
facts that can be shared that can be
hearkened back to that can provide
points of reference for current problems
I think what we certainly didn't reckon
with was
the proliferation I mean I'm old now the
proliferation of sources of information
that not everything that was written
down was true that that that this is
also literacy is also a vehicle for
communicating a lot of things that are
so socially harmful if not personally
harmful and so I think that you know
it's it's I'm I guess I did I mean it's
a silly thing to say but you know that
literacy turns out not to be sort of
earth-changing or human changing but
simply another tool in the in the box
that humans use and that it the the
optimism that I began with when I
started this work you know has sort of
certainly been qualified by the fact
that that's simply making people
literate does not make them either more
civic minded or more historically aware
or more politically astute but gives
them another tool which they can use for
good and bad purposes yeah one of the
things that is engaged with the idea of
technological literacy or media literacy
is essentially teaching people to be
skeptical of sources that you need to
verify sources that you need to be not
immediately trusting and which is a hard
thing actually that's not how people are
inclined to think I think and but still
I mean I think that premise gives us a
tool to work with that we have to
essentially work to help people
understand than they need to be
skeptical about things that come at them
electronically whether it's the internet
conventional social media or something
new like what's that I have a colleague
at Stanford Sam
Weinstein who's professor of history
education and this is his main
preoccupation now is how do we give
students multiple sources multiple
sources of information historical
documents and help them sort out what's
reliably true from those multiple
sources and it's a huge challenge
because you know even teachers are not
adept in technological
or an evaluating different sources of
information we want to be very artful we
could say we have to teach them to be
postmodern you know to not assume that
that which is in a very classic modern
way transmitted to you by seemingly new
and interesting sources is in fact the
truth you know we have to hope to become
skeptical of that one quick comment this
is one quick comment on that last I
think that there are some people who
would actually say that part of the
problem in media consumption is that
your average consumer is already
postmodern and doesn't trust anything
coming from anywhere which is a kind of
parallel question but the question I
wanted to ask is actually perhaps more
directed to David plank and it has to do
with the capitalist logic of Education
and the impact that that is likely to
have any educational reforms in the
upcoming government I mean I think one
of one of the small news items that I've
followed with most interest is the
degree to which various members of the
new cabinet have financial interests in
both distance learning and in the
privatization in one way or another of
Brazilian educational systems all the
way from you know early primary grades
through university education and the way
that that also converges in in many
respects with the agenda of evangelical
powerhouses in Brazil and so I wondered
a little bit what you would have to say
about that about what is likely what is
likely to be the impact of that
convergence and how people in the field
of Education are thinking about that
from the US yeah I think it's likely to
be very powerful and you know Brazil
relative to most other countries has a
very large private sector in education
now and particularly in higher education
and that partly because of the policies
of the new government partly because of
the amend the Constitution ah which
limits public expenditure that's all
that's certain to increase right is that
the the the participation of private
actors in the education system will
increase over the next
certainly the next well either over the
next month out - over the next 20 years
right so so so that will happen and yes
and but then that's compounded by the
fact that the backers of bull Senado
include many people who are deeply
involved in the provision of private
education and constituency's who are
deeply hostile to the state's role in
education you know seeing the state as a
as a as a front for leftists I mean you
know and and and unions and so on so so
you know we can we can see this playing
out in the United States right is is the
same thing is happening that basically
what what we're doing is dismantling the
regulatory framework that might reign in
private actors in the education system
and providing incentives you know partly
as a consequence of deregulation partly
directly to private actors to get more
deeply involved in the system and I
think that's what that's that's what
we're going to see in Brazil as well and
I would I would just you know influence
by the previous panel I would just say
that this has a history this is not new
that this this this happened in the 60s
and 70s and you know in the 80s and 90s
and will happen again but but louder
so I just wanted to pick up on the
previous question about functional
literacy so you know I think much of
this is and I think one could make the
point this has been the failure of
curriculum particular in the first and
second and third grades in in Brazil and
you know with the the problem of the
lack of the the failure of general
understanding which isn't critical for
for literacy and particularly functional
literacy this is a problem also of
course throughout America is in
including United States how much of the
scholarship and it does seem that
there's not a lot of interchange between
the u.s. and Brazil on that specific
specific point is there what needs to be
done and what can be what can be what
needs to be done particularly this
change of administration now I bring
this up because four years ago you know
the there was a delegation from the
Ministry of Education right when in the
beginning of the gentleman would term
which was Sid Gomez who was the Minister
of Education and there was Chris Tobin
Bakke many other halima many of the
other policymakers both in know from the
Congress and administration and that
initiative was in they discussed
formative issues in primary education
and how research can address that so how
can we bring that back on track
especially in this with this new this
new administration that's got to enter
so and and I'm gonna introduce what I
have to say but by saying I I said at
the outset that I'm familiar with some
areas of Education much more than others
and this is one where I had no special
expertise so so I can engage in
conversation about it but not I won't
claim to know I know what what my
colleagues do in education schools when
they think about literacy they think
about literacy as or literacy
instruction as a set of techniques that
lead to the acquisition of a set of
skills right so this is this is this is
basically a part of child development it
is
as sort of set of teaching strategies
that ensure that children are able to
read and then what they read you know
and whether they become critical readers
is somebody else's business I mean it's
it's left for later in the process and
you know becomes becomes a problem later
so so so I'm not sure how I honestly
don't have a good answer to your
question but maybe you can there was
maybe probably an old paradigm about
literacy but I think now there's
increasing evidence that literacy is not
just the acquisition set of skills but
there's an important component of
general knowledge in understanding in
creating in creating literacy literacy I
would I would just make a point that
there's a debate on that oh you know and
well and and and yes what do what you
read like what you have things to read
first of all and then what you read you
know certainly determines whether you're
able to remain literate and how you use
your literacy but but ya know I add that
to my knowledge at least is not an
explicit topic of conversation in the
u.s. all right well thank you very much
to our panelists and to everybody for
your participation and we will now break
for lunch and reconvene at 1:30
[Applause]
[Music]
you